why did the Google Glass flop was there
no demand for AR technology or they just
looked cringy or maybe they were too
expensive perhaps it was all of the
above and the biggest issue of all the
Google Glass meant the death of privacy
the glasses were fitted with a camera
that the user activated at any time
recording whatever he saw and this
naturally freaked people out oh you're
wearing glasses sorry you can't go into
the bar and they can't let you into the
cinema what if you decided to record the
whole film this is just a few potential
problems instead of being called cyborgs
people that wore these glasses were
nicknamed glass holes so smart glasses
that should expand human capabilities
simplify navigation and translate
directly from other languages quickly
pulled from the shells due to ethics
issues so the death of privacy is
canceled right Google is back with a new
version of the glasses and they promise
to fix the ability to shoot people
without permission so would you give
these high-tech specs a second chance
tell us in the comments